you
bah again and okay this is the last time
we gotta do this for this Disney sanfur
but I'm sorry when we saw this movie the
good dinosaur which we're going to talk
about like I have opinions but they're
not nearly as entertaining it is so I
had to bring him on board for this cuz
they're way too much fun um have to I
don't know don't get my hat or two no
Don I that's entertaining as you think
it's gonna dumb about I just your hatred
for it is so entertai well get don't get
too so let's talk about the good
dinosaur real fast
Oh probably not real fast don't we say
real fast but uh so this is Pixar's as
of now that we're speaking about a
possible first bomb in America
somebody tried postings somebody posed
up my Facebook page it's like well just
ten 100 million what do you think about
that I'm like that's great it cost 200
million bacon a hundred and fifty
million the market good luck oh but
which I'm kind of shocked that when
we're filming this what is today the
28th something like that yeah so this is
this is it made a hundred million when
was that thing released before right
before Thanksgiving yeah so I mean it's
definitely not the pics our numbers are
you know Jesus no worries in a day these
are the people that made fucking cars
too and profitable yeah yeah and this is
so this is an interesting film to talk
about uh this is film is every dinosaur
movie you've ever seen um pretty much if
you know I'm sure there's one from
Australia we haven't seen if you seen
any dinosaur story about a dinosaur who
has to travel out of necessity of
survival it's every dinosaur movie night
going this dog story yeah I mean I don't
know why this is always what we do with
dinosaur movies but that's what this is
this is it a supposedly interesting idea
why I saw the trailer that whatever kind
of didn't hit Earth a lot of dinosaurs
and humans uh you know evolved together
interesting dinosaurs were there first
so they look like you
Mary Muskett but here's what they do I'm
thinking like when I saw that idea I'm
like oh like Mavis will be like
dinosaurs the show cuz that was not your
typical dinosaur movie by any means I
was totally different and it was really
funny for ever watch it again they're
surprisingly really funny and kind of
dark um but so okay so dinosaurs are now
farmers and like their ink still I guess
kind of like the human primitive age
where they're like they don't have hands
they use their heads do everything but
there's all your harming without
opposable thumb yeah just using their
heads but there's only animal on this
planet that does that but it's not just
that there's also cowboy dinosaurs ah
that round up lesser forms of Wildlife I
just saw running around I'm going let's
ride even though we never see what
they're writing it does when you put it
like that you make it sound stupid and I
mean just just guess where this is gonna
go a young little dinosaur it's afraid
of everything
is with his family trying to make his
mark and his father is trying to show
him how to be a good dinosaur everything
you can guess from there happen
everything is that where the title came
from because always I don't know I would
say dinosaur yep I was actually very
confused because I thought watching the
film it should have been called the good
human but really the kid who steals the
show and the only thing that's kind of
different although again you could just
relate to Indy boy and his dog stories
same comes across this little human boy
who's also separated from his family
oh yeah that's the plot by the way
separate from family again if you
couldn't catch on and has to get home I
comes across this little boy that's kind
of like a dog can't communicate because
he's a little cave boy and they're even
more primitive than the dinosaurs I
guess but not by much um and he sort of
takes it as like you know a little dog
or whatever and they just go together to
find their families um so that's about
it and honestly just from like the base
level it's like what doesn't sound awful
and even honestly I didn't like this
movie but I didn't think it was I was
shocked
just how much the
public was hating it cuz critically it
wasn't it's like this is good I like it
but well it's Pixar so it's good and
it's like no no no it's clearly not good
but I didn't get quite the this is the
worst piece of like you know worse than
cars - worse than brave worse than you
know that kind of stuff maybe it's worse
than brave this Broadway it's worse than
brave I'll say that but um yeah yeah I
got a ranking worse than brave yeah you
really are right - yeah
no I I thought that would be the lowest
one for me for awhile but well no cars -
come on I didn't see I will say this I
didn't see monsters University oh yeah
oh that's toto I might as University
head like that was the first EXR film
maybe ever that I just took one look I
didn't but I didn't obscene cars - bye
didn't seen the theater I just saw
because we had a Disney separate thing
for the Disney summer there's other
protests are in a pretty thing we were
like signing stuff okay let's kill -
yeah one stone so but that was the them
definitely monsters University is the
first that I consciously decided I'm not
seeing this in the theatre and I have no
real desire to see it on video or got it
even that had a good message at the end
this one like I said just beginning to
end a school with a message well I was
it no it was the message she was
actually like it even if things don't
play out the traditional route you can
always find another way but it connected
a little bit more to like a college
rules and so it was smarter than I'm
making it sound the message was at the
very end but that's the last few minutes
um but I I will say I will give cars to
this there's a hot dirty fan it's
perfect
cars I always because that's how
imperative everybody who like replies in
the literally like they type in
exclamation points in capital letters
and by the end of it all of their words
blend into one super like they don't
even hit the spacebar anymore when I
mentioned they get so enraged I'm like
listen I'm not gonna claim cars - is
good um or even worthy of you know
taking a piss on
but it knows what it is it knows that
it's just there to sell it knows it's
there to sell toys it knows it's got
almost an awareness of light here's some
cheap shit to entertain your toddler it
is like aimed at a five-year-old level
this movie the good dinosaur is so
confused yeah it is now and when you
read about the production history it's
no surprise which is why when people
tried it like there and there is a very
small portion of the population that
tries to defend this film a lot of home
critics for some reason yeah I don't
understand how I'm knowing the history
of this film you can it's like the
people who fucking made it won't stand
by it like a number of people in Pixar
like yeah this we just it was a disaster
what can we tell you sorry like this
shit happens why maybe should've just
dropped it by the wayside and this one
thing comes new movies a year one being
inside out oh I'll be the good dinosaur
and you can tell which one works yeah I
mean this is not this is not to slam
Pixar when I say this and I know there's
always those moves like this is it this
is phantom Pixar they're finished wait
no I mean inside out well yeah inside
out was amazing I didn't like brave but
I I'm not sitting here like and I know
people it's like well they've got her
sequels down the road and I well worked
for the Toy Story movies and you know
what I haven't seen the trailer like I
just saw the trailer for finding dory
but I'm like I don't like finding Nemo
can be good I don't think this is the
end of Pixar I think it's a sign and
honestly I think it's a very healthy
sign that Pixar can put out a piece of
shit that bombs and it is like you know
what fine their feet are made of quick
yeah that define will recover and we'll
keep going we're not talking about a
studio that their third or second film
bombed and now all of a sudden they're
like shit what are we gonna do we have
the resources even to make another movie
now like you look at what's going on
with some other animation studios and
the way they're scaling back because
they've had bombs you
Pixar's not in that position no they can
afford to do this and good for them they
can afford to fail they can afford to
Bob that means that they've gone places
yeah so this is not to slam them but
yeah this movie sucks this you know let
talk itself like is every time I bring
up something good about it it's
immediately followed by something just
10 times worse the backgrounds in this
movie are unbelievable yeah I would
swear they just filmed it like it looks
unbelievably really think to some slight
degree they did cuz apparently they were
using like geo US Geological Survey maps
of like Wyoming and stuff's okay but I
mean like it just looks like they fit
but then that comes to the characters
the characters they look like 3d Gary
Larson cartoons and that doesn't fit in
these beautiful landscapes Linda jeepers
we were watching this and they show
mountains and fields and wheat and grant
Joseph yeah and we're cat in this soft
meow okay and then you see that first
dinosaur that Papa dinosaur which is
like problem I said that I just said one
of these things is not like the a really
doesn't go but there was a story or
something where it's like that would
work like that style would go together
but but if it is already inside out that
character design would be fine
yeah but in this film with those
backgrounds it is some of the most
ill-conceived his poor character design
I could ever dream up I just like who
thought this was a good idea
every time I see they cut to a
background of something pretty like just
an establishing shot huh and then every
time it cut to the characters I've
described it is watching Lawrence of
Arabia with Gumby and the lead role I'd
say yeah he's a gorgeous shots or a John
Ford movie or Lord of the Rings or
something amazing and epic and gorgeous
and beautiful of those and you've got
Gumby and pokey wandering grin you're
like no fuck is this
so and this the big thing too is that
this world clearly from and I lots of
movies are in production hell and go
back and forth watch the making of
inside out it's fascinating because
they're talking about like it wasn't
production hell but it's like
there were a lot of changes to frozen
lots of changes I mean all these things
were that just going back and forth
making changes to the very end and they
can turn out fine so I'm not saying
that's an issue I'm saying that with
this you could clearly tell it's an
issue sometimes a problem sometimes you
can overcome the production hell this
was a case where you cannot and it's all
and it's all over and I feel and in some
ways I feel bad for anyone who worked on
this project cuz it is embarrassingly
on-screen it's not even like a maybe we
can cover it up like like like a ruined
part of a cake
turn the backside to the wall or
something like that no the whole thing
is it did a disaster just a total
disaster and it's all up there on the
screen and like again I don't I don't
want to shit on the people involved coz
there's certainly artistry there I don't
even hate the funny thing is the
character design on its own like I feel
the dinosaur as emotion I know the pit
just doesn't belong here
yeah it's just so I feel bad for the
people involved in this cuz I'm like I
know there's talent there but it's just
one of those things where every sit the
perfect storm of Awesomeness every
single thing that would give you a
perfect storm of Awesomeness 180 degrees
wrong and it gave us a perfect storm of
suck whatever guys go go wrong
yeah um and it's one of those films
where it's like the another big thing
about it is the mood in this constantly
what else
yeah no no this is you know what Monali
and Kinnear imeem so dope tone is
everywhere okay do you like um
decapitations and do you like cute
little critters getting eaten up um now
I do but you know I knew he said it
belongs in uh yes Gibby well I died all
the characters like Oh what and stuff
and all the kind of very obvious humor
and obvious Dorian stuff like that ah I
like won't you say like two thirds in
they start with this dark no not two
three one third end they start with this
dark stuff it just immediately real um
are we doing spoilers here or not
um you know you're talking about the
first major one yeah just tell it
they're there everybody knows this okay
so spoiler alert yeah it let's just say
I won't give everything away it goes
full Lion King in the present yeah
oh but you can tell by the first minute
that's where it's going the thing is
that didn't bother me because that at
least was imbued with some sense of
meaning and gave the plot some sort of
purpose the right you know and when we
see in a million yeah you've seen a
million times but it at least there was
some sort of meaning attached to it the
rest of the darkness in this room is
completely random in the arbitrary and
doesn't it doesn't do anything it
doesn't even mean anything it's just
like well let's shove this cute little
furry creature in this pterodactyls
mouth for no reason
let's rip the head off this for a cheap
joke but I I think I say those for a
cheap joke you're right it didn't
benefit anything no I do and that's
because I got called a task because
somebody pointed out and like it on the
onset like they they weren't incorrect
oh hey there mr. fancy pants aren't you
the one who's automobiling said mr. fan
that they did um they totally did
they're like aren't you the one who
always does that eighty Sims kids films
are so much better because they with so
much darker and children should be
scared and blah blah blah and now you're
complaining this films too dark fuck's
your problem and you know at first about
well you know that's a good point I have
said that here's the difference and it
is a huge difference when you go into a
film that that we grew up in eighties
film let's say Return to Oz Dark Crystal
merican tail
American tail any of the Bluths how long
did it take you to figure out that you
were going to dark places even friggin
Wizard of Oz just starts off on kind of
like this downer mood there's just we're
gonna go we're gonna kill your fucking
dog and by the way here's a tornado
that's gonna swim yeah I mean there's
just this uncomfortableness there's this
feeling of wonder but there's always
this uncomfortableness throughout all of
it and this one just starts off you get
it fair bones
simple you know jacuzzi I mean it's Jim
goofy movie like it feels like it was
aimed at four-year-olds like kind of
the cars movie so it you know right away
in those movies we grew up with its
going dark places and even the omage
films I feel these are kind of homage is
to that eighty cellphone like Coraline
ParaNorman the first five minutes you
know that it's going dark places so as a
kid you're prepared it states almost
something getting okay we're gonna take
you to dark places your chance to leave
is probably have I certainly don't
remember a lot of films in the 80s just
being so sugary sweet and saccharine
cute and then like bringing out a
character like oh thanks are fighting
this free milk or shit you're not this
AB you know and this cute little thing
is you think and like the pterodactyls
like oh thanks for finding him and like
they go through the trouble to rescue
yeah this thing is trapped big rescue
he's like all thanks so much risk using
the turned actors look home like in his
job and I'm just like okay no I like the
two of us we're our jaws not just the
big lad should even bigger was one the
kid decapitate the bug why why was it
out or else we're just you know what
it's like a good example imagine like
the chipmunk adventure the Alvin the
Chipmunks movie somewhere in the middle
like when they're escaping from the
snakes they just break its neck like
that I mean that's the fame it just
doesn't match the breath oh that's where
the think of the bug didn't bother me as
much because I put the lion king to bed
to like apparently bugs have no souls to
Disney nobody fucked oh yeah I had I
mean blanking also like Pearson yeah
liking always I felt had a darker
element from the beginning but that what
bothered me about the critters I thought
okay well maybe it's still alive in the
jaws then just to fuck with the little
kids heads even more they start playing
tug of war with the tail that is
sticking out of this pterodactyls jaw
literally give me that give me that and
unlike that was a once living creature
just like sitting there probably half
chewed to death in this pterodactyls jaw
now they're fighting over the furry
bushy
else ticking I'm like this is fucking
sick and then the movie started off with
this sort of darkness I would have
probably been okay with it but to come
out of nowhere like that I'm like Jesus
well and on top of that it doesn't feel
earned I mean like we've always said
about Dark Materials like it's five it
has to feel like it has a place I has to
feel earn another thing I'm realizing
with this movie even though on I can't
say these are like the worst characters
or anything is that when I'm watching it
every single time I saw a new character
pop up I'm like oh this type of
character I didn't feel like oh now this
is a unique new character I'm being
introduced to like joy from inside out
or Woody from Toy Story Andy there was
no sense of this is a new person I'm
being introduced I felt like oh this is
this stock character to serve us not
purpose in this time the Triceratops I
think was the only one that was like I
want to know more about this guy and of
course it fucking leave that that is
true there's no Triceratops in his house
so bizarre and so strange
once again didn't match anything but was
just so friggin weird I was like okay I
kind of wish I knew more about him um
and I think the problem is the holster I
feel like what happened was everybody at
Pixar and one of their since Pixar is
like so open-ended apparently it's a
pleasure to work and they have game
rooms and stuff I feel like everybody at
Pixar had some giant pizza party and
they all got kind of stoned and they all
decided to brainstorm a bunch of ideas
for a dinosaur movie and instead of
sobering up the next thing going okay
let's cross this out let's cross this
now again that didn't make any sense oh
you're way trash buddy now that's I go
in there all right here's about the
three ideas left that maybe we can make
a movie out of instead of doing that
they just looked at the whole
nonsensical is diamond yeah fuck it
let's throw all of these in the movie
hmm and that's what we got there's just
there was like no self editing it is
like so many different ideas and that's
probably because of the production hell
is wider because I'm here collects in
the kitchen that it just ended up being
this giant mess well I feels like
there's an idea here that's like you
know let let this bloom let this idea
can't bloom you're talking about how it
seemed like their riches too may
deism they didn't cross them off I
almost feel like the opposite I almost
feel like you know there's a lot ideas
that could can come from this because I
like the idea of the common not hitting
or it then what would that mean but it
isn't allowed to bloom like I said that
the sick con it's over to make this
comparison but the sitcom dinosaurs I
think took better advantage when I said
there was more opportunity to that's the
point though that's because they were so
focused on having so many different
ideas that they didn't take just one two
or three ideas and expand on them they
just let's just touch upon these twelve
ideas without really going in-depth into
any of them should we talk about the
t-rex cowboy subscribe yeah so Sam
Elliott is in this I was really hoping I
would like a fucking love Sam mi-17
guessing but talk about just random I
like and Sam Ellie it plays a cowboy
t-rex wrangling up what were they even
wrangling up by Friday I remember but
apparently it's their follow sores I
don't know yeah like and and but
wouldn't you know but not some Raptor uh
Wrangler rustlers yeah Lhasa Raptor with
velocities are stealing their friends
ins up to the good dinosaur Sam le
Miller's that catch them mangy rustlers
and stop them from stealing the food I
like that but I'm a fuck is going on I'm
watching this you know cuz they're yeah
they're same stuff like which let's be
honest now yeah like let's ride jihad
son but clearly not riding anything but
they're trying to make it look like they
are like they're holding on to reins and
they're just going like this while
they're running and it's like well
clearly we know what you're trying to do
but why and how is it entertaining or I
I really just wanted like Sam Ellie's
the t-rex have a coconut this okay yeah
and you remember what happened what he
said let's ride he says like Sam Elias
is like alright let's ride and I just
heard you nice it right what just is so
right ourselves of just riding their
tails haha it's just so ridiculous and
that's the problem it's like it's not
for adults it's too aimed at like a
preschool level for adults but it's not
for preschoolers either because it is
death and decapitations and guys when we
saw this movie uh they were kids
running oh my god Wow this movie is
going not little beginning all right
it's like the middle of the movie they
got so bored they were just running up
and down the aisles and it's what I
imagined it didn't bother me I found
some more dirt it I will say this it is
what I imagined the Raptor pit must look
like when you lower a cow in there like
these kids is laughs like just
everywhere going nuts they were running
in the aisles the parents are trying to
control them and I'm like this is a sad
testament to how much this movie is an
abject failure because I've been in
plenty of kids films where the kids are
all well-behaved and like wrapped up in
the movie the Todd Bell kid don't laugh
you know they'll always be that but like
the level of just I don't give a shit
from the age three to twelve crowd in
this cinema we saw it and it was a full
cinema was just epic one like they just
you could not pay them in candy to sit
down and watch this film well when we
were little kids we had dumb crap like
the Care Bears and stuff like that and
we sat down we watched it because it was
bright colors it was this is obviously
for your two or three year old or we
give you the bright colors just to
distract but this didn't even do it this
didn't have the bright cog this had very
grown-up realistic backgrounds with very
bright colorful characters well mainly
just one color but and they're not doing
them like they're just kind of talking
to each other these lame jokes that you
know kids either aren't can understand
won't care about because it's not an
environment they can get sucked in to um
so it's it's very fast it's a
fascinating failure oh yeah I can't say
I hated it quite as much as a lot of
other people do but it's it's definitely
not good I hate it more be let me put it
this way there is no potential in cars
there is you say the plot and you're
just like oz is for five-year-olds like
this you literally can see that the toy
packaging as you describe the plot of
the movie it's cars in the
fuck it's like they have a real society
any cars and you're just like okay
alright I can see the toys-r-us ahead
already
this one though if you told me it's like
oh well it's like dinosaurs and it's
it's following this dinosaur around and
maybe there's a cave can that's about
getting back in these epic landscapes
the potential there is so great that
that's why I think I hate it I think
that's why a number of people who
dislike it really fucking dislike it
it's because there was so much wasted
potential there's no potential in cars
or cars to and I didn't see monsters
University but now it's protector yeah
you know at best you know I could argue
it's like okay monsters you was okay it
was fine and then there was a moral but
it's not like there's a ton of potential
there like this is gonna be high art
when I look at the landscapes like in
this film and when I see at least some
of the story concepts the barebone
concept behind them like there was so
much potential here again by the way for
another fucking dinosaur movie that
could work but instead they keep talking
and keep aiming all of this at like the
preschooler level like that other stupid
dinosaur moving to have you're a
dinosaur I said yeah all these dinosaur
movies have the same fucking trailer by
the way where it starts off at none of
the dinosaurs talking it tricks me every
time and I think finally we're gonna get
a dinosaur more where they don't talk
where it's like some sort of Discovery
Channel documentary where we get to
watch dinosaurs just interacting and
it's kind of fun but artsy and kids are
doing this is stepping just talking it's
stupid jokes you know I'm sick of it
it's bent with what didn't land before
time come up loads of late 80s yeah we
might be looking at 20 years now it was
like 20 plus fucking years and we're
still making the same goddamn movie have
you made even more um but yeah I was
gonna say honestly the years 30 years
I'm not good at man
- spent a number of years so ship for me
as sailed I think after the movie
dinosaur even if they were to release a
movie now where dinosaurs had to get
from point A to point B and they didn't
talk I wouldn't watch it I wouldn't care
cuz I'm so sick of that story now I am
just done with it and you know what
kills me is it's been 20 plus 30 plus
years what ever since Lane before time
and nobody's made a single goddamn
dinosaur movie as good as that hash
better they land before time and
Jurassic Park doesn't count it's a
different sort of dinosaur movie I'm
talking about like a kid's cartoon
dinosaurs one actually following a hind
of source yeah on their back was pretty
good name is your score yeah that's a
good question is this as good or bad as
we're back I think that's a good
question
oh that's honestly I like we're back
better because it's so surreal and so
strange and you know what when it has
those Tonga's moments are out of nowhere
and strange I do feel a little bit
tender does even though big spell sense
honestly I could see kids sitting
through we're back a dinosaur story
being more interested in it than this
yeah like that sort of that madhouse we
saw I don't see that happening in we're
back a dinosaur Easter I'm not saying
we're backs good no it's like we're back
is a different kind of madhouse it is
the weird bright colors it is themed
like we're in this one is what that's
going where where is the potential there
so at least it's like yeah so it's just
a waste but there's some realness of it
is so strange and so odd when they're
trying to have the tender moments it's
like liking see how this could work it's
like with this it's like so far behind
and so standard I'm like no this can't
work now once again credit to the master
down blue nobody's done it as good as he
did it back in the late fucking 80s um
so yeah I'm trying to think you know
I'll say oh the one scene I kind of
liked in this I liked when I liked how
the boy dinosaur in the boy the cape boy
uh explained how they're both separate
you drawing of that I thought that was
clever and the little sticks and
everything the now made
imagine I imagine this for one second
imagine if there was no dialogue in this
film oh yeah
scene that that all that be how much
more powerful with that've been oh yeah
what is and it was barely any dialogue
in that scene at me that's one of the
reasons if that's what reason scene
sticks up oh and I like the end you know
the animation on all the characters that
it's kind of standard Pixar's it's good
it's not bad and what I say it I really
like I really like the animation on the
boy I thought the expressions and
everything we thought the expressions I
feel like they're getting better at work
bill moments and just sort of still
having young expressions we're fine and
that's the thing that's why I feel bad
when I say some of the most piss-poor
character design ever put the screen
it's because it doesn't match the layout
work but there's nothing wrong with the
animation I mean it's no one looks
better than fucking normal enorus ya
rabb shiniest a polar bear derpy derp um
so it it just doesn't Majan I think
that's why I hate it more because that's
another case of where wow there was
talent behind the animation in these
characters just like there wasn't inside
out but because nobody had somewhere
within the 18 iterations of this film in
its production history held the the
wherewithal or the foresight to be like
you know maybe we shouldn't put these
two separate things together it just
comes off is so wrong and it destroys
all the talent that went into it I see
like a very clear idea of light you're
somebody's idea are two people's idea of
like what it was going to be and then
just like either all the notes from
themselves or other people or whatever
just everybody else trying to change and
stuff like that just turned into
something completely different I heard
brave it kind of the same thing happened
uh which effects they look kind of serve
the both very gray looking and that very
colorful brave was another where all of
its problems were not to the same degree
I feel was worse than the good dinosaur
but they were also embarrassingly all on
the screen where it is like oh so we
have this story of this mother-daughter
relationship and it seems pretty serious
and look at this gorgeous animation and
then what are the
three little brats and kilts here doing
with all their fart Joshua fear okay
yeah and now she's like another one
where it's it's like there's just too
much shit going on there like somebody
need to be rain somebody and be like no
like just choose one or the other
um so I think you know how I put it like
and this is where the talent goes to
waste
imagine you have the world's greatest
ice cream chef make a great ice cream
and imagine you have the world's
greatest sushi chef like make some sort
of sushi with the seaweed and everything
and then they're like that's great I
love what you guys are doing now we're
gonna make it one dish bomb together
yeah that's why I could sit there and
say well this is the world's worst ice
cream dish and the world's worst sushi
dish
even though individually they're fine
that's again to go my foot in it I think
that works as someone who has tried
lobster ice cream by the way which was
literally just ice cream with lobster
pulled on top and it was some of the
worst things I ever had my life I can
testify it doesn't work so and I was a
real dish some place um but yeah I think
I I think that's about it
I mean I'll say that I think you can get
the idea there's nothing like
quote-unquote like so bad that it's like
oh you'll get a lot laughs it's so bad
or it's so incredibly terrible that you
know no kid should see it it's not quite
that right it doesn't quite normally
we're entertaining their kids I don't
know how much enjoy the only way I
recommend it is for the layout work I
will say the layout the layout and the
background work is so amazing that again
that's why I hate it more than cars do
because like all that gorgeous talent
put to waste
hmm um but yeah if you if you're into
animation and you really like I love
background work a lot of times I'll
watch it anime if I'm going to be more
interesting what's going on in the
background of the foreground so if
you're into that sort of thing I would
recommend it as something maybe the
check out don't expect a good movie
attached to all that imagery but mmm
yeah so um too unlikely anyone that made
the movie is watching this but if you
are watching IV it's like keep going I
am me there's great talent by this
people and I'm sorry sure I'm use all of
you guys individually did good work yes
it's just a somebody decided to make a
sushi ice cream sundae out of this so um
if but if you enjoy sushi ice cream
sundaes maybe you'll enjoy this uh I
think that's about the best thing we can
say about it so uh that's about it and
we'll see you for the last video or
maybe a few videos to depending on when
this comes out uh Disney summer we'll
see you then later